[Music]
after Deadpool one came out of nowhere
and made everyone lose their minds a
sequel will rise that's just as good if
not better
making audiences everywhere say now this
one's good too it's like having a
surprise party but this time it's not a
surprise and it came three weeks after a
funeral Deadpool - in a world where wait
wait wait wait wait wait
hold the door hit the brakes cut dead
who know it's Banksy would you like to
buy a painting yes it's [ __ ] Deadpool
let me guess where you're going with
this one in a world where bla bla Disney
bla bla TJ Miller blah blah blah
pretending to give a [ __ ] about shatter
star hey that is not what yeah yeah
you're right that's pretty much what
we're gonna say why the [ __ ] are you
even doing Deadpool to listen to your
commenters and tear KOCO a new ass all
already
but koco's are really sweet movie and
Deadpool - isn't alright nuts
hit it blind al what's happening
uh-huh from whatever internet company
owns them this week comes a YouTube
format that's been chugging along for
six ten years even though everyone knows
they peaked it frozen think it's time to
let it go man honest trailers be honest
trailer in a world where comic book
movies are actually in great these days
no evil well most of them watch these
nerds find one logic gap and pretend
like it ruin the whole movie well
actually if cable changed the future if
you wouldn't have to travel back in the
first place good point
no you pedantic horse [ __ ] it's a movie
about a cyborg cartoon with huge pouches
and tiny feet stop pretending it's the
real world revisit all the classic
honest trailer tropes like the park
where they just say bewbs for no reason
actually we kind of moved away from that
smart choice the part where they're
slower fans keep requesting trailers for
movies that are still in theaters unlike
Deadpool - super duper cut available now
on blu-ray and Digital and the starring
section which actually isn't bad but my
movie did it way better like half of
yours are just bad puns Joe Pepsi
Gary's nice Beverly Hills Club Helen
rearview mirror and Carlie they're on oh
yeah well you still are Jesus joke don't
talked about in the same sentence as
Jesus Passion of the Christ then named
Deadpool is the highest-grossing r-rated
movie of all time except for Jesus that
I said on our video I do not need to be
here I could be playing fortnight with
Drake ninja and Mike Pence right now
sorry sorry my bed carry on
starring nobody you've ever heard of
dead horse that made me all kinds of
turgid I don't know it seemed a little
harsh I mean we have been nominated for
three Emmys wait what three Emmys oh
come on this is a king outrage we're
done here
wait don't go
he'll be back for detective Pikachu but
good more flavor than fruit stripe gum
this is the purple walrus volcano
nightclub you and your ham sandwiches
are welcome on yelling words super easy
barely an inconvenience what is a king -
a god